there's almost like a renaissance of
like how big stand-up and comedians are
with how podcasting is going and kind of
like where
comedians fill the gap of what's missing
in mainstream entertainment these days
do you feel like it's like a great time
to be a comedian
this is the best time ever i'm i'm
excited i hate to i hate to say this but
it's like yeah when you have oppression
and like all this weird [ __ ] going on
like it can only create great art right
it can only inspire you to be like yo
[ __ ] is crazy let's talk about it before
we're all dead you know i mean before
another asteroid hits this [ __ ] right
or before the aliens under the sea so i
can be like ah we got it you know what i
mean so this is the best time there's
there was black lives matter year last
year before that you had you know
everybody met at trump with me too and
then daca with illegal immigrants right
then you get this pandemic that washed
everything and now we're back to the
same [ __ ] really like everybody leaned
on that black lives matter and all that
other other [ __ ] right it's not
really [ __ ] it gets in the social
conscience but [ __ ] we outside now and
like the [ __ ] didn't change right you
know what i mean especially in comedy it
was like they leaned heavy on it just to
virtue signal it and now it's like we're
back outside and it's like they're just
yelling at each other now you know and
like nobody can spit
nobody's spitting like dick gregory or
even you know patrice o'neill or even
like chappelle today or rock it's like
we're still leaning on chappelle to be
like give us the truth give us the truth
and it's like why is everybody else
giving us the truth you know what i mean
and i'm not gonna name names got to work
with these casts but i like that damon
wayne's who's one of the who's one of
the greatest of all time is like yeah
i'll do a versus against dave chappelle
like that's the kind of energy you want
you want dudes who are like i can spit
and i'm gonna show you i can spit like i
ain't dead yet [ __ ] as richard
pryor would say right or even bernie mac
it's like it's not the same anymore
nobody's afraid to get in trouble like
that's what makes the art great is like
if you're not afraid to say something
because we are you know the village
idiot right but we are kind of the voice
of reason too because
we're bringing it down so you can be
like oh that's true we should be better
than that you know what i mean